LED POI are some of the most amazing
tools that PO Spinners have ever been
able to acquire back in the day your
options were pretty much either to use
fire po that would leave a bunch of soot
on you or to use sock poy that once
again you probably made yourself and
that weren't very useful after dark and
then LED po really changed the game not
only could you continue to practice at
night but all of a sudden those trails
that the props were creating were
standing out in ways that they never had
before and I would like to share with
you five of my favorite picks for tricks
that led po are uniquely suited
for Drex here from Drex Factor po
sharing with you the love of pois
spinning and flow Arts to benefit your
body and brain and today I'm counting
down my top five favorite LED poy tricks
but before we dive in let's just give a
quick shout out to the Friends of the
channel big thanks to dark bunk fire
Mecca flow fests flow toys juggling
calling pyrot teror light toys spinballs
and Ultra poy for helping to make the
videos on this channel possible you can
learn more about all these awesome
companies and the work they're doing to
support flow artists like yourself by
checking out the links down in the
description of this video and special
thanks to the non- business friend of
the channel Becca Becken thank you so
much for supporting my channel my work
and my mission so it seems kind of weird
to think of LED po as being a specific
genre of poy tricks but I think there's
good reason to do so with both fire as
well as daytime practice POI you can
more or less see the body of the
performer that means that you can see
exactly how the PO is interacting with
them and your focus is on both but with
LED POI it's kind of Hit or Miss whether
they're bright enough to illuminate the
performer but what they do do is they
make it really really obvious what the
trails of the patterns that we're
creating happen to be in fact I think
it's no coincidence that the Zenith of
the tech po movement happened about the
same time that widespread LED po became
available and so with that in mind I
wanted to see if I could come up with
five specific poy tricks that really
benefited from the LED treatment but
that also meant that I had to make some
choices as to what counted and what
didn't because you can so rarely see the
body of the performer that meant that
body tracers and things like plane
breaking moves were out they require the
knowledge of where the PO are in
relation to the performer I also wanted
to Veer on the side of tricks that were
a little bit welln if for no other
reason then I didn't want to get super
Niche on this there are a lot of
opportunities that LEDs present and I
want to honor that and furthermore I
wanted to diversify the list as much as
possible so I'm only going to pick one
trick from a given family of Po moves
cuz otherwise the entire list could
basically just be rap moves glow
stringers have known how to play around
with glow props for much longer than we
have really we're cribbing from their
playbook for a lot of this so with the
rules set here are my five picks let's
dig
in trick number one
weaves yeah okay so it is not the most
daring of choices but I do think that
there's a good reason to stick it here
see 3B weaves already look cool and were
a deep part of the PO tradition going
even back as far as the M practitioners
back in New Zealand but there was
something unique that happened when we
switched into LED props that really made
this trick Pop I remember thinking that
I wanted to learn a 3B weave based upon
seeing it done with LEDs for the first
time and let's be real any of us whove
ever had a photographer use a long
exposure on us or added trails to our po
moves almost certainly started with a 3B
weave if for no other reason then it was
one of the few things that we knew and
well it still looked good unless you
think the 3 beat weave is boring we have
the option of doing pulse weaves Archer
weaves Archer fountains fountains in
general waist wraps there are all kinds
of possibilities for what we can do with
weaves and all of them create really
interesting and unique trails in and of
themselves so this one is an essential
trick for this list and speaking of
essential tricks for this list I'm going
to get one of the obvious ones out of
the way early
so trick number two spiral
wraps yeah so again I could have
literally just made this entire list
nothing but different types of wraps but
I wanted to make sure that I got a lot
of different types of tricks on here and
thing is how I couldn't leave off wraps
entirely I had to pick just one and
let's be real it's going to be spiral
wraps in a lot of ways I think that
spiral wraps have been are and always
will be the ultimate expression of wraps
they look so beautiful and there's
something about that spiral pattern that
just activates something Primal in the
human brain that likes seeing the golden
ratio they're also the rare LED trick
that is dependent upon the human body
but actually benefits from contact with
it rather than the human body
disappearing being something that makes
the trick less interesting they're great
for switching the direction of the PO as
well as creating suspensions they're
also great for changing planes and well
you can switch them into a one-handed or
meteor place these things are so
incredibly useful I have never grown out
of them and I don't think I ever will
all right so we've made a stop in
Waveland and we've made a stop in wraps
land next up we're going to be playing
around with
levels trick number three
windmills it's me so of course there's
going to be something in here that lends
itself to a dancier kind of position and
being as how you can't see the body a
lot of the time when you're spinning
LEDs that means that when it comes to
level changes the poy have to do all the
heavy lifting windmills are one of few
ways that you can make a level change
read whether or not you can actually see
the performer's body bringing the PO up
and around our shoulders is something
that is Crystal Clear if you're starting
from places that include weaves and
thread the needles and just like with
our weaves there are a whole bunch of
variations that make windmills read in a
whole variety of different ways you can
take the high and tight version that
just keeps the windmill up around your
ears or you can expand out to the povian
man version this one I especially like
to emphasize by doing under curves and
over curves with my hips again the
audience might not be able to see my
hips moving but they can absolutely see
how much it exaggerates the movement of
this particular windmill highly
recommended all right so by now I'm
willing to bet that there's a bunch of
you out there that are really dying for
me to drop a more intermediate or
Advanced po move so here we go trick
number four the
Mercedes so I'm going to be real I will
go out in a limb and say that the entire
reason that the Mercedes became a thing
and more than that a really popular
thing is because of the widespread
availability of LED po probably more
than any other trick on this list the
POI Mercedes I associate with long
exposure photography and the Zenith of
the tech po movement I think these two
things are not at all a coincidence see
I remember back when the Mercedes caught
on absolutely everybody in the PO world
had a long exposure photograph of it
that was their profile photo and every
single time it was done with LED Po and
led POI specifically of course there are
plenty of other moves that reflect
aspects of the Mercedes from being able
to go back and forth with the Mercedes
in different directions to also being
able to do caps in a variety of
different places around the body but
fundamentally we are talking about a
contrast between extension and anti-spin
and no other type of prop has ever done
it better than LED POI so real quickly
before I share with you the final trick
on my list for those of you out there
that are still working on some of the
lower tier tricks on this list I have a
resource that will probably be helpful
to you the flow circle is a weekly
exclusive lesson that's available only
to my patreon supporters in the month of
May we're focusing on weaves and
specifically the performance potential
of weaves everything from how to explore
volume with them to traveling across the
stage as well as things like being able
to add and some track degrees of twist
to either side of weaves even better
than that our final lesson of the month
is going to focus all on isolated weaves
one of my favorite Advanced poy tricks
of all time you can sign up now over
patreon.com X Factor POI the first
lesson is already available all right
friends so now it's time for the final
reveal my single favorite LED poy trick
of all time yeah it's it's it's
orbitals trick number five
orbitals so this is another place where
we as po Spinners are kind of cribbing
notes from our glow stringing forbears
and it's kind of a shame because I never
see this performed anymore but I've got
to say when it comes to tricks that
benefit specifically from what led po
can offer well there's never been
another trick that benefits from this
more than an orbital there was is and
continues to be something that is just
magical about bringing together two Po
in a tangle and having them spinning
together so rapidly they just seem to
blur together into a single disc and of
course at a bonus points when you take
it around your head because all those
little bits of your head and face that
you illuminate as the POI go around them
oh perfect something that is always
guaranteed to get an audience riled up
is making the Poise spent really really
really fast and there are not many ways
that you can get them to spend faster
than they do inside of an orbital it
really is just kind of an amazing
demonstration of conservation of angular
momentum and of course some of my
favorite variations on orbitals include
the ability to do little anti-spin
flowers with them as well as being able
to do little stalls that make each po
jump out for just a moment and of course
my personal favorite when you let go
with one hand and you wind up in a place
where you can convert that orbital into
an entire meteor pretty cool right and
that's why the orbital is my favorite
LED po trick of all time what did you
think of my picks were there any of your
favorites that I missed leave me a
comment and let me know what they were
also be sure to like share and subscribe
to help other people find this video and
to help my channel grow
[Music]
this video would not have been possible
without my amazing patreon supporters in
particular I'd love to give a shout out
to my flow patrons who are listed on
screen right now thank you so much for
supporting my channel my work and my
mission and if you out there watching
are not currently a supporter but you'd
like to become one you can do so by
heading on over to patreon and sign up
at
patreon.com drexfactor poo there you'll
get access to a whole host of really
really awesome rewards but even better
than that you'll be helping me out in my
mission to bring po spinning and flow
Arts to the the whole wide world go
check that out please and thank you and
if it has not escaped your attention
that led POI are particularly good fit
for different kinds of poi patterns well
you can check out a list that I made of
my top five favorite po patterns which
overlaps with this one just a little bit
I'll go ahead and uh leave a link to
that down in the description as well as
up on screen thanks so much for watching
make sure to get out and flow yourself
today and I'll see you with a new video
real soon take care now peace